this is all it takes to make your own
animal-based sunscreen this is really
terrible advice homemade zinc oxide
sunscreens do not work that well it
isn't just about the amount of zinc
oxide it's also about how that zinc
oxide is distributed zinc oxide loves
sticking together especially if it's
uncoated and non-nano that's partly why
most zinc all set in sunscreens is
coated and Nano so you end up with
larger particles which means that they
protect less of your skin and they also
absorb less UV and reflect more visible
light that's why they look white so it
puts this extra clumpy zinc oxide into a
bunch of oils and mixes it up with a
hand mixer that's not powerful enough to
unclump the zinc oxide you need a higher
Shear homogenizer specifically designed
for this not something designed to make
cake and even with the proper
ingredients and Equipment it takes
formulators a lot of optimizing and
testing to get a zinc oxide sunscreen
with a consistently High SPF some
researchers made homemade sunscreen
recipes with up to 35 zinc oxide and
estimated the SPF none of them got over
sps-6 so this is really just an animal
based diaper cream